cinéma vous avez peut-être vu les très
beaux dessins animés le voyage de
chihiro et la princesse mononoké du
réalisateur japonais miyazaki son
premier film était inédit en france 15
ans après il sort sur les écrans
enfin richard tripoli c'est assez joli
commun mais alors comment tu as fait
comment est ce que je suis tombé des
cieux une petite fille prénommée cheetah
descendu du ciel un petit garçon
orphelin qui travaillent dans la mine la
rencontre de ses deux enfants c'est
celle de deux mondes se du ciel et de la
terre avec un secret apportée par
cheetah tout là-haut derrière les nuages
il y à un château une forteresse
convoité par des puissances maléfiques
il est à ma famille depuis des
générations dans cet univers fantastique
cher au réalisateur japonais
cheetah est plutôt vont s'envoler vers
les étoiles vaincre les forces du mal et
bien sûr retrouver le château perdure
réalisé dans les studios de tokyo les
histoires et les dessins de miyazaki
sont inspirés par des auteurs européens
comme dickens swift ou jules verne mais
aussi par ses propres voyages au cours
d'un voyage d'une promenade il ya des
choses qui me frappe et je me dis
maintien je les utiliserai bien la
prochaine fois du coup de mon prochain
film il y aura des paysages de patagonie
et les accents l'univers de miyazaki est
telle qu'un véritable musée lui est
désormais consacrée à mithaq à près de
tokyo un endroit où les enfants peuvent
retrouver les personnages de shiro
mononoké totoro et autres robots comme
celui-ci issus de son dernier film quand
j'étais jeune je voulais être philosophe
parce que j'étais préoccupé par tous les
problèmes du monde mais en voyant ma
tête je me suis dit que j'avais plutôt
l'air réjoui
alors j'ai abandonné
cet amour de la philosophie miyazaki la
mise au service de la beauté de ses
films avec un scénario d'une grande
richesse
l'alternance d'action et de repos
d'humour et de gravité
ce château dans le ciel nous fait rêver
et réfléchir